humans can experience over 10 million  colors it's rather amazing but not to  the mantis shrimp beautiful isn't it  this is a mantis shrimp mantis shrimp  have 16 color receptors in their eyes  the most of any animal on our planet  what does this mean now think about the  world you live in you're experiencing  all this with 3 optical receptors  because the mantis shrimp has so many  more than us they're light detecting  ability is astronomically better and  this can help them spot prey quicker  making it an extraordinary hunter it's  only about 4 inches long but can strike  with the force of 335 pounds well it  takes nine pounds to break a nose 25 to  break a small bone and 400 to break  through a block of cement the movement  of the mantis shrimp claw is one of the  fastest for any animal on earth they've  even been known to break through  aquarium tanks remarkable